rich asks what advice do you have for
professors to engage college students in
the classroom what about outside of
class which is the biggest thing for you
and any professor out there or if you're
asking for somebody is that professors
aren't relevant to a lot of their
students today more than ever because
the behaviors of how we act aren't map
and meaning so many people have emailed
me like literally because the show
emailed me that hey I'm in class right
now and what my professors talking about
makes no sense compared to I'm watching
your palm listening to your podcast
right now while my professors talking
because he or she r so I literally
professors in major universities that
are putting kids in debt right now are
telling them that there is no roi in
social media like Ludacris horse crap on
this crap kick anyway I think the
biggest thing a professor can do is to
be relevant with them if you're a
professor right now and especially if
you're marketing your comms professor
right now and you're not jamming on Yik
yak and snapchat and the insta then
you're making a huge mistake because
you're out of touch with your sins
you're saying dumb [ __ ] like hey kids
hey students we're going to connect
through modern things like you know like
just I can't even come out of my mouth
I'm so disgusted with what's going on
universities across this country and so
its relevance there is a rolling and
checking the [ __ ] out going on in
classrooms all across this country and
it's sad because of the romance of how
professors think it should be versus the
reality of what it's like oh crap wait
subscribe I need subscriptions because I
can't push this many right hooks in
social so subscribe